we are here with Grantchester advisory
board director michael kozakov stick
that has some exciting news for the
coming year in the Grantchester thank
you for having me
we have tradition and final day of
branches tour here in London to make
announcement of our plans for the
following year and every year we make
certain surprises and 2019 is not going
to be exception and we would like to
announce that we are going to expand
branches tour ready for expansion and as
we spoke in the beginning of origination
of the ground chests or we envision that
Grantchester
will go to all continents and in 2019
it is our fifth edition of the
Grantchester and we go beyond Europe and
America we're going to Africa and Asia
well that's a little bit more about
these tournaments what can we expect
from the coming year so in the coming
year we can guarantee seven tournaments
for rapid and leads to classical events
and finals like we have right now and in
London and we will have the same format
looking forward to qualify players from
the regular season till the finals like
we do using NBA NHL and finals will
determine the winner of the ground chest
or perfect and you were telling me
earlier about a new partner here for the
tour will we have sponsorship and
branding partner game plan sports it's
our new partner that will be helping us
to find new sponsors and new promotion
all over the world and to us about the
players that will be participating in
the next two or who can we expect I know
that at least the three qualifiers from
long
we'll be participating next year of
course we have our qualification system
that three winners of the grand chest or
2018 automatically will be qualified to
play and we will find out today however
we need to wait until the end of the
year to find other qualifiers because we
qualify them by universal rating system
and by average feeder rating so
therefore we need to wait until the end
of the year and to see what ratings will
look like and then we will make
announcement about other players who
qualify well I can guarantee that we
only have at least 10 players
participating on a tour we increase
already from 9 to 10 and it is
guaranteed already and it is very
possible that we will increase
participation up to 12 because as of
right now having our new branding
sponsorship partner we have already
discussions with additional sponsors and
new venues will be possible and it might
be possible that will we have more than
seven tournaments in 2018 but I can
guarantee the seven that I just
announced
well that is excellent news here for
chess fans thank you Michael for sharing
this with us
well it'll be more than just third and
fourth place that they're fighting for
here in London as Javier Corona and
Levon Aronian are clearly fighting for
more than that thank you Michael and
well let's see what brings in the next
year for the Grande chest tour
you